Pass ja auf dass du es nicht fallen
lässt
ja eh
denn doch eben die Modalpartikel
[Musik]
ja
die andere Person weiß etwas bereits
[Musik]
ich hätte gern eine Schachtel Dromedar
Zigaretten
musst du heute nicht arbeiten
nein ich habe dir ja gestern gesagt dass
ich heute nicht arbeiten muss
wir haben bei unserem letzten Meeting ja
besprochen wie wir vorgehen wollen
habt ihr eure Arbeiten erledigt
ich habe eine E-Mail geschrieben
ich habe euch ja eine Mail geschrieben
wann kommt Papa nach Hause
erst morgen er arbeitet heute ja in
Salzburg
[Musik]
wir sind ja ganz alleine am Strand
das Essen sieht ja lecker aus
ihr habt ja einen riesigen Garten
diese Übertragung funktioniert ja sehr
schlecht
im Imperativ stärkt ja die Aussage
[Musik]
wären sie sich ja nicht
mach ja nie mehr so eine Unordnung
kommen sie ja nicht ohne Maske und
Schutzausrüstung in den Raum
ja vorsichtig Kinder
Fahrt ja vorsichtig Kinder
doch
man ist überrascht dass die andere
Person etwas nicht weiß
[Musik]
sie wissen doch dass ich immer nur
Kaffee trinke
ich habe doch gesagt dass du aufpassen
sollst
doch ein Paket bestellt
sie haben doch ein Paket bestellt
es ist doch nicht meine Schuld dass das
Schiff abgefahren ist
im Imperativ macht doch den Satz
freundlicher
[Musik]
beobachten Sie doch den Stern dort
trinken Sie doch einen Cocktail
wie komme ich zum Kino
probieren Sie das Kleid doch mal an
[Musik]
denn benutzt man nur in fragen
wie schmeckt euch denn das Essen
suchen sie denn eine Marketingfachfrau
hier sehen wir einen kleinen Stachel
Kaktus
dürfen auch einen großen Stachel Kaktus
gibt es denn auch einen großen Stachel
Kaktus
haben Sie denn Schmerzen
und eben
Halt und eben benutzt man wenn etwas
nicht zu ändern ist oft auch in
Klischees
hier muss ich halt warten
hier muss ich eben warten
das Flugzeug ist halt verspätet
das Flugzeug ist eben verspätet
chinesisches Essen schmeckt halt sehr
gut
chinesisches Essen schmeckt eben sehr
ich muss halt den Schnee wegräumen
ich muss eben den Schnee wegräumen
[Musik]
man ist sich sicher dass etwas so
passieren wird
[Musik]
das ist einfach das versteht ihr
das ist einfach das versteht ihr eh
mit Yoga werde ich abnehmen
die Situation hat sich geändert
jetzt funktioniert etwas nicht mehr
[Musik]
ich gehe jetzt rein
es beginnt eh zu regnen
die andere Mannschaft hat drei Tore
geschossen
jetzt gewinnen wir eh nicht
das sind einige
Modalpartikel lernt die Modalpartikel
möchtest du noch weitere Videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren Kanal jeden
Sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere Videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren Kanal jeden
Sonntag ein neues video